this episode sponsored by the awesome
socks club a sock subscription for
charity
sign up between now and december 11th to
get a new pair of fun socks
each month of 2021
when you've been on a journey through
the microcosmos
there are some names that start to feel
pretty familiar
anthony von levenhook comes up pretty
often as befits a microscopist whose
delightful descriptions of the bacteria
and protozoans essentially
birthed a whole field of research then
you've got
muller and your ehrenberg your du jardin
names that endure because of the
microbial knowledge they are attached
to alfred detliff fritz call
has one of those names the more you look
into the literature to identify ciliate
the more
his name comes up and yet he's probably
one of the
more mysterious figures of microbiology
we know that he was born in 1877 in a
town
north of hamburg germany and we also
know that he was a high school teacher
who taught english
french and natural history but any other
details of his personal life
are obscure except that he had a
daughter
lucia who attended a series of lectures
about protozoans
at the tropical institute of hamburg and
we know this
because in one of his works call wrote
quote the very interesting literature
and preparations my daughter lucia
brought home
fascinated me as a dedicated biologist
and created the desire to study this
field more deeply
so carl did what people who develop a
curiosity
for the microbial world do he got some
water from nearby and he put it
under a microscope the year was 1924
and carl dedicated himself to studying
the literature
and mastering the microscope
using a bright field microscope he would
use a micro pipette
to take an individual specimen and watch
it at low magnification with no
cover slip at this point he could gather
information about the organism's overall
shape and movement and then he would
apply the cover slip
elevating it with little dots of
vaseline underneath the corners to keep
from crushing the ciliate
with the needle he then very gently
pushed
down the edges until the coverslip was
applying just enough pressure
to render the organism immobile but not
so much
that the slide would squish it to death
the process is delicate and it takes
time to master
but it works call estimated that it took
him about
nine months to feel confident in his
drawing and identification skills
and from there he went all out
his first monograph was published in
1926 when he was 49 his last publication
came around 1935 and in that period of
time
he published 21 papers that totaled
around
1800 pages of descriptions and
illustrations
of around 700 new
species of ciliates
yes 700
for reference in 1974 the microbiologist
john o corliss described what he saw
as up until that point three ages of
ciliate classification
the first period lasted roughly from
1880 to 1930
and he named it the age of discovery
scientists during that period
discovered around 500 species
in the course of a decade call
more than doubled that of course
call was benefiting from advancements in
microscopy
and experimental techniques and he was
building off
an available base of literature and yet
his accomplishment still stands as
uniquely his he was largely working
alone and yet
through careful work and dedication he
probably discovered more ciliates
than anyone else ever has carl's
contributions extended beyond
just uncovering new species the second
age of cilia discovery which lasted
between 1930 and 1950
was marked not by a need to just uncover
new species
but to understand how to better group
them
by the end of just the 1930s there were
around 3
000 known ciliates to classify leading
to the creation of new taxa
and genera that some have called khalian
classification
because of the labels he introduced into
it though of course like many
microbial taxonomy efforts these labels
would undergo
massive changes in later eras of
research
the third era that corliss described
lasted between 1950
and 1970 and this era would apply the
advanced techniques of those days to
better the relationships between the
roughly six
thousand species known at the time and
of course those relationships are
still being revised and updated with the
new techniques of today carl's
classification system
may not have lasted but maybe that's
part of its value
our understanding of microbes is marked
by so many stories
of how we have attempted to classify and
reclassify
and reclassify again and given how many
species
we have yet to encounter it is a task
that will likely never end during his
lifetime his work invited its
share of criticism some took issue with
his methods while
others disagreed with the definitions he
used to distinguish species
but while call acknowledged the feedback
his careful and thorough work
would produce descriptions that still
endure and inform
our understanding of ciliates but his
work
seemed to come to an abrupt end in 1935
for reasons that are not known
some have speculated that he was
frustrated with both the criticisms from
academic scientists
and the challenges of getting his work
published there's a manuscript from 1943
submitted to the journal
microcosmos aimed towards amateur
microscopists like
khal but whether there was meant to be
more
would become irrelevant khal died in
1946
and those who have looked into these
questions have found
neither an obituary nor a grave
there are mysteries both microbial and
human to this story
and if call helped us solve some of the
former
he left us with more of the latter just
as we know little about the beginning of
his life
we know little about the end of it as
well it's really just that decade of
work
that seems to have lasted but oh
how it has lasted alfred kahl's texts
have gone on to become immensely
important to those who study ciliates
filled with drawings that help those
like james
our master of microscopes who are trying
to figure out
what they see under their microscopes
the tools may have changed the ways we
share information
has evolved but the delight and the
curiosity
that remains unchanged thank you for
coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
you may have heard us talk about the
awesome socks club already on this
channel
but we wanted to make sure to let you
know about it again because you only
have a few more days
to sign up the awesome socks club is all
about
keeping your feet cozy and giving money
to a great cause
it's a charity sock subscription where
100 of after tax profit
will go to decrease maternal and child
mortality in sierra leone
the socks are lovely and fun and i'm
wearing a pair right now and subscribers
will get a different pair of socks
designed by a different designer every
month of 2021
but so we can control inventory and
reduce waste
signups are only going to be available
until december 11th
it's only a few more days if you're
watching this video on the day i went up
if you're watching it a week late i'm
sorry
you have missed out if it sounds like a
club you want to be a part
of head on over to awesomesocks.club
microcosmos to sign up now
but as lovely as the awesome socks club
is certainly doesn't pay all our bills
so thank you so much to all of these
people
who are on the screen right now these
are our patreon patrons and they allow
us
to make this show all of the episodes
none of them could exist without the
support of these people
if you would like to become one of those
people go to patreon.com
journey2micro to join on up if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby